um now during this time also
you stayed in the navy reserves which
means you were doing your one weekend a
month or whatever
and then we go back to the book then an
unexpected opportunity came up as a
naval reservist i could attend basic
underwater demolition school at naval
special warfare
training complex in coronado california
buds is a six month long training class
was part was the first part of navy seal
training so if i ever wanted to become a
seal and member of the
naval special operations community basic
underwater demolition school is where i
had to start my wife sarah
knew that being part of special
operations had always appealed to me now
this opportunity was sitting right in
front of me i had undergone
training as a rescue swimmer in the navy
so i had assumed
i had the swimming part down when i was
approved to attend the six
month buds course visions of becoming a
seal danced in my head
i quickly found out how tough it was
during the first phase of training
a pre-buds training course that lasted
around three weeks
from there i went on to phase one which
consisted of eight weeks of grueling
exercise and conditioning
topped off by hell week typically more
than half the recruits wash out
sheer fatigue and sleep deprivation
cause every candidate to wonder what his
limits are
the non-stop beating that our bodies
took from some of the hardest training
the military has
followed by long stretches of being cold
wet and miserable
with no time to recover took its toll
when my boat body broke down from a leg
injury and severe pneumonia
i was dropped after three months of
training i could have tried again after
i recovered but i couldn't bring myself
to go through all that [ __ ] again
yeah so what was uh what was that like
going through buds
or attending buds yeah buds was um
i mean i was class 242. uh i i have to
say we were a beatdown class
that's that's just my opinion um you
know how they have the classes where
some of them are oh man that's you guys
got secured early from hell week or what
not then next class is man you guys are
a beat down class or whatnot
well we we had a beatdown class and it
was uh it was intense
everything that they talk about it um
yeah
the only thing i can tell any listener
who wants to
contemplate that route is do it because
it's an experience that you'll never
forget
they will make sure you will never
forget it 100
so it was the worst part you think for
you because you know different guys
they dislike different things what do
you think was the worst part for you
for me the worst part actually
once i got pneumonia um i couldn't
breathe
and so under when so when we were doing
um drown proofing and whatnot like that
i just
my nose would just start you know
opening up but
i would i would have to say anything
like on on the water
fine under the water i i don't i don't
really like that
i'm not i'm not a very big fan of that
so when uh well we'll go back to the
book here
for the first time in my life i
experienced a major setback
becoming part of an elite unit was
something i wanted with every inch of my
being but i couldn't make the cut which
prompted a series of questions
why did i fail why wasn't i good enough
how come my body broke down
was i that weak i had no answers and i
came up with every
every poor me excuse in the book you'd
think that for a guy who was raised the
way i was excuses would be the last
thing on my mind but they were my crutch
i slowly but steadily turned myself into
a victim
if only i didn't grow up in a broken
family if only the world and everyone in
it weren't against me
that just wasn't about buds but me not
making it through
brought my buried demons to the surface
so even at this point you know you don't
make it through buds
and you kind of blame all these
you know hey it's all cause i was raised
this way i had these you know my dad my
mom wasn't around
and you kind of make those excuses for
yourself yeah i
i buried i buried myself in excuses and
it it became very easy to do that it's
very easy to
to make somebody else the issue instead
of
looking deep inside and and saying hey
man just
you know if if everyone can make it then
it wouldn't be buds
and so um instead of understanding that
you know i i did i took the it was it
was more
it was almost more entitlement than it
was victim is like
well this isn't fair why why didn't i
make the cut and the thing is i could
have rolled back
but i don't know how
how far did you make it um all the way
up to the end of the first phase
so it was yeah it is basically they
wanted me to go
um back to day one of phase one and i
was just like
and you know i just i didn't have it in
me so
but yeah it's you know it's it's one of
those things i look back on
you know and i i do i don't ever regret
anything
but it is one of those things where i'm
like yeah you kind of
you kind of [ __ ] that one up you know
so
yeah well uh you know when you say you
had a beatdown class
more than other people it's like i'm
gonna tell you the classes
are beat down classes they are beat down
classes you're gonna get beat down you
know
i was over there a few months ago with
one of my friends that still works over
there
and you know he was like there's there's
whatever there's like a hundred helmets
by the bell
and um and he goes every single one of
those guys
is a stud that wandered he didn't say
ever see he's like almost every single
one of those guys is a total stud
that showed up here thinking they were
going to be a seal and they rang that
bell man
and they go i go it's crazy he is he's
like it's it's crazy that's the way it
is
it's a crazy process it's a crazy
machine yep um